[Music]
most of us ride this train everyday we
not we say hello but how much do we
really know about each other
[Music]
it's my first time on a commuter train
I'm sorry if we met no I'm Joanna
what if I asked you to do something I
could prefer the effects of individual
on the street I don't understand it's
just one little thing
on this train does not belong all you
have to do is find them why would I do
it in the bathroom there are 75 pounds
of tars that money is yours if you do
this one little thing
I thought this was hypothetical you have
until next stop to decide what kind of
person are you
Michael Michael McCauley they're
watching
I am NOT gonna do this look outside
southeast corner don't make me hurt
someone you love it's all over the news
there's a witness who's that deep with
the wrong kind of people
if identified someone on this train is
gonna kill him
what do you know
you have no idea we are up against I'm
done playing games
now everyone does
I'm not gonna let them hurt you
you're trying to set me up we have a
hostage situation take them out just
stop this right now
I asked you to do one little thing
[Music]